hey guys Pete here mr. robot season 2
episode 9 is in the books
we got quite a few answers to lingering
questions and a whole bunch of new ones
to think about this is will be my mr.
robot season 2 episode 9 recap and
review so let's get right into it we
start the episode with the flashback
once again and this time we finally see
what the knock at the door at the end of
season 1 was Elliot finds cops at his
door and gets locked up for unauthorized
use of a computer and theft for stealing
that dog flipper was my personal guess
of why he was in jail so I was satisfied
with the reveal but was still confused
on how he would have been sentenced so
quickly it's processed and then we see
him talking to a lawyer who says that
they can get to hacking charges reduced
he lets Elliot know that the theft of
slipper would be a little bit more
difficult though since the plaintiff is
really upset as the lawyer is talking we
get the first of many situations where
Elliot stares off into space and the
person talking to him has to ask a fuse
alright tells him to plead not guilty
and we cut to the courtroom Elliot goes
in front of the judge via webcam which
is pretty standard the judge asked him
for his plea and after a long awkward
pause he goes against the lawyers advice
and enters a guilty plea the judge does
his duty to make sure he understands
what he's doing he doesn't want to
change his mind and then immediately
sentences him to 18 months for the
charges no expert on courtroom procedure
but I feel like this is a little off
maybe someone that knows more can
enlighten us in the comments but to me
it seems odd that you would be sentenced
the first time you go before the judge
either way Elliot ends up locked up
which we assume was his plan from the
beginning mr. robot makes a quick
appearance to try to talk him out of it
which reinforces that the whole thing is
an attempt for Elliot to get away from
him as they process him in we see that
Lone Star is a guard and Ray is the
warden when he enters population Leon
comes into the picture right away he
lets us know that the inmates have
already heard of Elliot since he was
arrested arraigned and sentenced all
within 24 hours he makes light of this
by saying that Elliot is the only guilty
man in the entire pen he gives him a
rundown of the routine and we see some
of the familiar faces around the
basketball court I guess what's
important here is we see how quickly
Leon reached out to him
learn about how he got started watching
Seinfeld we also learned that Leon is a
man who can get things any sorts of
things and Eliot asked him for a
notebook we eventually seen him crossing
into the space where everything becomes
his mom's house instead of the prison
the illusion that he built up Elliott
explains to us that this is everything
that we missed and then we see him
getting out in present time the
corrections officer who is releasing him
fills us in on the rest
he tells Elliott that he has the hack to
thank for his early release he says it's
messing with the economy which affects
the prison budget and that he has never
seen so many nonviolent offenders
released this early on his way out
Elliott mentions the episode title when
he says in it five return to normal he
then asked if it is possible to return
to normal after spending 86 days in a
6x9 foot box mr. robot walks up beside
him when he gets outside but doesn't say
anything at all
as he leaves through the outer gate we
see that Darlene is waiting for him she
gives him some french fries and a hug he
hugs back and then we see her whisper
something in his ear but we can't hear
what she says see Angela grabbed a
rubber ducky that Mobley gave her a few
episodes ago and then we see her calling
a receptionist she does a little social
engineering to get her to leave her desk
and then slips into her boss's office to
steal his passwords there's a tight
moment when someone comes to the door
looking for him but she think but he
just thinks that angela is the
receptionist she heads back to her own
office and is able to access the account
she pulls files about the Washington
Township plant and copies them to a
flash drive from there we find Elliot
and Darlene getting on the subway she's
filling him in on what happened with
Cisco and how he was talking to his dark
army contact about the femtocell and
states - she also says that she can't
track down trattner Mobley and that
Trenton's family has filed a missing
persons report Darlene says she's
worried that she thinks the dark army
might be cleaning house Elliot says that
he that doesn't make sense because he
thinks they were behind his early
release he says they need to get
together with her contact which we know
she bashed over the head with the
baseball bat they think they are being
tailed so they end up in a building
where we find out that their mother
Elliot says he needs to go see her and
does which makes for a curious scene he
thanks her for helping
get through the past months and says he
couldn't have done it without her she's
unresponsive and never really looks up
so he says that you know what he has to
and then he leaves we find out white
rose is in the u.s. at a graveyard with
her assistant he's visiting the grave of
the last CEO of ecore who we find out
was in the midst of a scandal and was
about to shut down the project later we
learned she meant the washing the
township plant but at the time we just
get the idea that white rose had
something to do with the death before
they leave if she takes a piss on his
grave Elliot is that Cisco's with
Darlene he's in the bathroom he over
here Cisco and Darlene arguing in the
other room about the femtocell in stage
2 as Elliot looks in the mirror he hears
mr. robot say something outside the door
and that meant that really takes him by
surprise as he seems to be in two places
at the same time Darlene yells his name
and tells him to go back to earth or
come back to earth she mentions trying
to find threatenin Mobley and Elliot ask
Cisco for his dark army contact he
reluctantly gives it up and Elliot you
know decides to run an exploit that
turns on the microphone on the Contacts
phone as he's setting it up mr. robot
asked and what just happens and it seems
clear that something is going on with
them being in two different places but
neither one of them knows why white rose
is now dressed as minister Jane to meet
with Philip price he mentions that
Angela really came through for them and
that things worked out better than he
imagined but then price tells him that
since the bailout failed they can't
afford to keep up with all their
facility he says the US government will
be taking over the Washington Township
plant which Jiang is obviously not okay
with price offers a way out he tells
Jiang that if they can get the Chinese
government to give them a loan to solve
their financial crisis then e Corp will
be able to keep control of the plant and
the overall flow of the episode this
seems to be a minor detail but as
someone who's been watching and picking
over these episodes I think this might
be the most important thing that
happened I've been trying to make sense
of what the connection to the plant is
and haven't come up with anything that
worked I mean they are showing us that
this plant was you know that was
responsible for killing Angela's mom and
Elliot's dad has been white roses
endgame all along according to the wiki
the plant is a chemical manufacturing
facility or factories I don't know why
whatever
they're doing there would be so
important that White Rose would be
willing to kill over it's clearly not
the only chemical factory in the world
but it is the one that was near where
Angela Elliott grew up here are two very
powerful guys talking about something
that's clearly high stakes for them and
each has their own pond and play who has
direct ties to Washington Township Rice
uses Angelo to get a set settlement to
go through without an independent
inspection clause and White Rose works
with Eliot to derail the company that
oversees his own interest I guess right
now it doesn't matter until we know what
stage two is but we'll get to that later
you know in a minute to sum up the end
of their conversation White Rose makes a
veiled threat you know to kill price and
then price tells him what's up White
Rose agrees to go back to the Chinese
government who he says will be agreeable
and again tries to stress that press
needs to not threaten his plan at this
point price tells him he's a mercenary
and goes off on a rant and ends with
price saying that you know he does
whatever he wants and that he will do
whatever he has to even if it hurts him
he says that he would rather see White
Rose lose them when himself and he
threatens to you know rain down chaos
back at Cisco's place Elliot is working
on taking control of the dark army
contacts phone he says that F society
all had the intention of changing the
world but they never really knew what
the dark armies intention was mr. Rambo
tells Elliot that something is off that
he feels like they're overheating and
Elliot says that they'll be fine he gets
control of the phone mic and then tells
Cisco they need to set up a meeting with
the contacts he says he wants to ask
them about stage two and even though
even if he doesn't get an answer it will
get them talking about it which they'll
be able to hear Elliott eventually talks
him into it but mr. robot is concerned
that they won't be able to pull it off
we next see Angela at the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission office she's
delivering documents that show the
Washington Township plant still has
dangerous levels of toxicity the agent
tells her that what she has is big that
they have to protect her anonymity and
that there may be money for her as a
whistleblower in the situation so she'll
probably need a lawyer
she says she isn't doing it for money
she just wants it done quickly and he
says that he will take the information
to the deputy director he takes all the
information including the
Drive and leaves her in his office Ellie
was on the subway where there is a
strange looking man playing a mini
keyboard we noticed that he's not very
good at it and that he is the only other
person in the train car as the team
starts to annoy him Eliot walks to the
door where he sees mr. robot and Cisco
talking in the next car down he tries to
open the door but it's locked he freaks
out some while the guy with the keyboard
never notices and then he sort of comes
to Cisco tells him that they're at their
stop back at the apartment we see
Darlene listening to the dark army
contacts conversations she looks up at
the TV as they are talking about the
operation Berenstein Lee as they show
the clip of fsociety Darlene realizes
she might have left the broken VHS tape
behind she checks the camera bag and
realize she doesn't have it we also see
the first flicker of the lights which we
hear later our brownouts we also catch a
shot of the date on the laptop at the
end of the scene that tells us that it's
August 6th Elliot and Cisco are at the
library and the dark army contact comes
in when he sees Elliot he decides to
leave on his way out
Elliot shouts to get his attention when
he turns around Elliot says to tell
whiterose he wants to know what stage
two is back at the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission angela is still waiting and
we see the lights flicker again at the
same time the deputy deputy director
comes in and explains that it is related
to one of the electric companies going
on strike they walk down the hall and
the director starts asking Angela
personal information she says she
thought that they would guarantee
anonymity but the director continues to
press saying that Angela works at Ecore
and asked her what her position is there
this freaks Angela out so she asked for
the files and drive back the director
tries to assure her that her colleagues
just want to talk to her and then Angela
decides to leave without getting the
files it's a creepy exchange but there
isn't much in the way of clues as to
what is actually going on Angela might
just be paranoid but the woman seems to
have an agenda compared to the first
agent she talked to there are several
shots of the cameras in the hallway
which I'm not sure is feeding into the
paranoia of her being on tape or if
perhaps somehow she noticed they weren't
on or something Elliot and Cisco get
back to his place and Darlene
tells him that she forgot the busted VHS
tape Sisko tries to assure her that they
wiped down the whole house and that he
is sure they probably got it but she is
convinced the tape is still there she
reminds him that her face is on the tape
so he agrees to go back and look for it
even though it hasn't that it has been a
month since they were last there Darlene
and Elliot are on the couch and it looks
like he is still glitching back and
forth between personalities she tells
him he looks tired and that he can sleep
on the couch but what then we see mr.
robot who says no that his own place
will be better
she says that they'll be watching him
and that's you know he says there that
that's the all the more reason to go
home he needs to show them that he's
leading a normal life
she tells him to be careful and then
they leave Angela's back in her
apartment and hears her doorbell ring
when it looks like she just came right
back in she basically pushes her way in
tells her that she brought some food
asks about whether it is Egor pausing
and then sits down and starts eating
Angela asked her to leave and Dom tells
her about a dream she had we know from a
previous episode that Dom said you know
she said that she doesn't dream at all
so it this had a big effect on her she
says that dream started out good that
she was with a beautiful woman but it
ended with her being choked under water
she then tells her that all he told her
about the disc at allsafe
the very first time she pulled him in
she says that they have been having her
trach for the past two months which
included her field trip out to the
Nuclear Regulatory Commission Dom says
she doesn't know how all of what they
know actually ties together but
eventually someone's gonna connect the
dots
she tells her she still has one card to
play and that it's her she tells Angela
that in her dream when she was being
choked it wasn't until she stopped
fighting that she survived and then she
puts her card
you know her business card on the
counter and leaves we see Cisco enter
madame executioner's house to look for
the tape he finds it where they left it
and then he turns to leave as he's
headed to the stairs he hears something
which he realizes to someone laying on
the floor in the room we can hear
labored breathing but we don't get to
see who it is Darlene is still listening
to the contact who she hears meet up
with Wildrose just as Elliot planned
he tells whiterose did Elliot
to know about stage to whiterose answers
that that doesn't make any sense since
stage two is Elliot's plan in the first
place Darlene looks shocked to learn
this but then the scene cuts away we see
Eliot walking across the street and he
talks to us about normalcy never being a
part of his life he says he talks to his
dead father talks to us and then says he
would ask if we were Noma but we never
answer we go back to Darlene who was
still listening white roses asked if
Eliot mentioned Trenton and Mobley and
when the contact says no he figures out
that it was a plan to listen to them
talking he takes the phone and then
Darlene loses the conversation as she's
processing what happened we hear a knock
at Cisco's door she gets up to answer it
but of course we only see the somewhat
shocked look on her face before it cuts
back to Eliot as he makes his way across
the street to his apartment we noticed
that an SUV is running outside of his
place he tells us how can things return
to normal when the SUV of the man he
murdered is sitting outside of his
apartment he says normal I have no
normal and then we see inside joy
Johanna says hello Ali and the episode
ends so just a boatload of stuff going
on with a large dose of cliffhanger we
had the bombshell that white roses plan
has always involved the Washington
Township plant and that he has killed in
order to keep whatever he has going on
there moving along this is likely
related directly to the creepiness
Angela experienced at the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission that oh yeah Dom
knows about - Eliot or mr. robot came up
with stage 2 from the beginning only he
has no idea what it is
Dom has been watching Angela for two
months and knows from Holly about the
disk they used to infect all save you
might conclude that since Elliot and
Ollie never really got along that this
mean Dom knows Elliot is someone to
watch but the way it went down all he
had no idea the disk was connected to
him for like eight episodes we had been
wondering who was knocking at the door
of end of season one as soon as we find
out we end another episode with the
mysterious knob does this mean Darlene
is going to disappear and who did Cisco
discover on the floor or the couch or
whatever over at the smart house we're
left with a massive amount of questions
once again just as season two is heading
into the final stretch we only have
three episodes left and I think we get
the last two in a doubleheader just like
the two season premiere
was how much of this are we going to be
able to get answers to there are a lot
of crazy theories going around some of
which are plausible but I don't see
enough evidence to start getting into
them yet starting to think that this
will be how we spend the entirety of the
offseason now that white roses cat is
out of the bag why does he care so much
about that plant with his power and
resources why can't he do whatever you
know he got whatever he's doing there
why can't you just do it somewhere else
I have read theories about mind-control
experiments psychological programming
and other ideas that suggest that Elliot
is the product of whatever it is he's
been doing there if that were the case
then you know where does that leave the
FBI it's really a lot to think about
which makes this one of my favorite
episodes of the season I'm not sure if
Elliot's condition is getting worse in a
progressive way or if the glitching has
to do with the stress of getting out of
jail
Angela's personality seems to be
changing and it's not clear if it is due
to what she's been up to there's this
you know a lot of people have pointed
out how she stares into space that's not
really how she was before and if you
think about it it's a lot more like how
Elliot is so there's something going on
but you know there's just no way to know
right now for sure Trenton and Mobley
are missing unless one of them is who
Cisco found and Elliot is about to have
Joanne on his ass one way or than the
other since he just doesn't know where
Tyrell is let me know in the comments
what you think is going on we knocked on
like who knocked on the door at Cisco's
place for that matter who else from our
story even knows where he lives
who does Cisco find in the smart house
what a stage to why his White Rose so
worried about that plant and what was
going on at the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission it's a lot I know please like
the video if you found it interesting
and subscribe to my channel let's watch
the rest of season 2 together and try to
figure it out in the comments thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon